les rideaux de cette boîte de nuit se
lève mais ce n'est pas pour une soirée
dansante
depuis un an cette discothèque lilloise
parmi les plus fréquentés de la capitale
du nord voit ses portes fermées à cause
de la crise sanitaire
le propriétaire christophe en profite
pour faire des travaux dans son
établissement
il ne sait toujours pas quand il pourra
rouvrir trois psychologiquement pas
avoir normalement ne pas avoir de de
prévisions sur une prochaine ouverture
ça c'est compliqué parce qu'on sait pas
où on va mais aussi des crédits
j'ai des enfants donc tout ça aussi plus
financer aussi haut
à titre personnel on a discuté avec les
syndicats qui mènent mes confrères qui
tiennent des boîtes de nuit
effectivement nous on aimerait vous
where he mais moi j'aimerais pas ouvrir
sous n'importe quelle condition
clairement si admettant qu'en jouant
n'ouvre qui paraît peu probable il nous
mettrait des réglementations sanitaires
par exemple pas maître de piste de danse
en france les discothèques ne sont pas
reconnus comme des établissements
culturels et n'ont pas pu ouvrir l'été
dernier si l inverse des bars et des
restaurants
les professionnels du secteur se battent
pour obtenir cette reconnaissance auprès
du ministère de la culture
alors que le printemps approche
l'inquiétude est toujours palpable chez
les gérants de discothèques le monde de
la nuit rêve plus que jamais de revoir
le jour